hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay
doing some stuff trying to find where
okay I've been in that one that's where
the axe murderer was I got a Hall key
maybe Susan door stores locked how about
that own I want to use it no this is it
but okay there we go there we go okay
that's it I'm still not do thanks gotta
get out here there
oh no I had the knife what the hell get
out here get out of what what is that
they just ran me with their heads and
then they explode I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know oh man oh
okay outside thing all this is an
outside let me get dead get dead man get
dead oh my deal with you haha
stop with the uppercuts oh oh give me
the gun give me the gun give me the gun
Oh what is that what is that
radio Oh I'll save this please oh why
did I come in here
I did not come in here all the radio
turned off thank you
okay because anything actually in here
besides an axe murder
ah you know up bang bang bang Oh dead on
not surprisingly a gun is powerful okay
I went somewhere ah oh I don't know
where I'm going
oh but I'm okay
tougher than this bring it on
whoo okay the bathtub or their bathtub
their fourth floor am i finally on the
fourth floor this one was a DDD
was a good one okay very nice to kill
easy to cut with my knife like to cut
food yeah you're sane perfectly sane in
here in where oh you're dead you're so
dead man always totally blocking all
blood everywhere why am I going in here
ah no
okay for some reason I'm lagging a bit
now the frame rates kind of dropped a
bit Oh No
do this to self oh boy what is the frame
rate low how can you tell I'll trim ah
no no I would love my frame rate to go
up this is half-life one we're talking
about and I got a beast of a computer Oh
okay
how do I get down no I get down ah do it
wow what are you what are you can't
reload maybe I can't reload with one
hand yeah ok I'm getting out of here cuz
it's laggy ah come on
ok I gotta get out of here somehow
oh let me save let me save just in case
I don't know if there's an autosave
function I better save every time I
can't sorry about the low framerate but
there it's it's not my computer it's
just something in this level and
screwing it up what do I do
seriously what do I do oh I see bro okay
I got the rope I guess a rope here oh no
no use that here we go okay I just got
to drag it to the use oh the frame rates
still low what the hell is going on come
on if you just stab yourself in the head
after you died that made sense
Oh another clip okay I got to get out of
here I just got to get to different
levels and the lag is just awful
I don't know why ah now team horse hang
on I got a I got a pausing here
something's obviously going wrong
something has gone terribly terribly
wrong so um I'll be back hello everybody
and welcome back i I don't know why my
framerate dipped like that took care of
it oh good thing I came back because I
missed those magazines anyway it's
better now so hopefully it won't happen
again I don't I don't know why I had no
Hannah virus running or nothing so I
know you're there hobb dead
yep you stabbed yourself in the face
good job
all right um okay there don't budge okay
getting out into the next place
get four shots that's all it takes to
kill those things they weren't here
before is it God magazine give it give a
lady okay
still making progress okay
I know I've been in here before
okay this is haha lady and that that is
a freaky enemy I can lie just waiting in
the bathroom for me to pop out well I
vote choo-choo-choo baby okay
I'm searching another knife because the
knife doesn't have ammo I need a shot of
morphine oh man
sploosh oh yeah
oh that's stuff okay back to the knife
don't let me down man I don't even know
where I'm going I think I'm supposed to
get to the basement I'm out of I'm out
of jump shoes oh stop screaming stop
screaming lady oh oh
okay those bars weren't there before
oh go on the right way because they're
putting enemies in my way okay I got to
switch back to the gun because I'll just
make sure to reload whenever I can
where am I going where we going it was a
body there before oh boy oh man
this game is freaking me out wow what
the heck
okay that's weird yeah the game wanted
to freak me out I am thoroughly freaked
out no guy lady your haircut is out of
style and so is your dress
okay now I'm gonna take the time to
touch the gun no that's not my gun
reload oh wait I just wasted bullets oh
it doesn't have its realistic gun okay
please tell me this leads outside not
yet okay I'm back here I was here before
I didn't go up so I'll go up
I don't think I'm gonna go in there I'm
not even gonna touch that door just to
joke about it oh crap oh crap okay now
as I need to kill some kitties I stuck
the elevator in the hall so the only
personnel can access it by a secret code
I guess no kitty you'll find that out
they will just have to take the stairs
oh I don't want to know I don't want to
know don't wonder cuz then you'll find
out oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
Oh anyway I gotta cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching I really do
appreciate it
oh man whoo this game is getting to me
so I'm gonna try to keep going in a row
I'm doing recording this a lot a lot at
a time
but I may have to take a break here soon
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in the next part
bye bye